one of the beautiful things about
america
the second amendment uh is uh we also
like
individual freedom that's one of the one
of the unique aspects
at the founding of this country and
still and for me
is the beacon of hope that uh
somehow there's the fire freedom burns
in there like that texas feel that i
that gives me hope the fu
energy that revolts against the
power which as we discussed power
corrupts and ultimately leads to sort of
uh degradation of the whoever's
ruling is the people it's interesting
though like it seems to me maybe i'm
just i don't know if i'm reading this
properly when i when i see it but it's
it seems to me that
that like you said that that you know
flip the bird i'm gonna do me
within reason like as long as i'm not
hurting you uh
is idea that that very much at least in
my mind defines the american ideal or at
least part of the consciousness of the
united states
is is under attack to a certain extent
you know um in
if only like i can think to like you
know maybe a generation
behind us um it's it's becoming
more collectivist yeah you know for all
the good and also the not
good of that and it's uh you know not in
not in term
not in terms of policy at this point but
just in terms of like uh
the consciousness and i wonder if that's
a an internet thing you know people are
more in touch with one another than
they've
as far as i can tell they've ever been
or at least more than in my lifetime
and uh you know the rest of the world
seems much closer than it did you know
living in virginia
california seems very far away being on
the internet it's just right there i can
hear about it i can see it
i can i can interact with people from
there you know i remember uh
you know being in tennessee at uh you
know one time and then
and reading about you know events taking
place in you know the middle east
and it just seemed like a mile away it
seemed like a
unbelievably far distance and then
another time when you're in dc you just
feel like oh you read about something
happening in paris and it just feels
like it's just right around the corner
because dc is a seat of a seat of power
where things are just occurring all the
time and
uh you know i guess you you wonder about
that's where i come back to the group
decisions to
not listen to this person or to cancel
this or to you know we all
the moral majority shall do the
following as opposed to as long as
you're not hurting me
and long as you're not hurting anyone
else i have to let you do i have to let
you be on general principle even if i
don't like you i'm very free to not like
you i'm free to speak out against you
but i'm not
it is not within my right or and not
with it and it's not
i i would not be right to attempt to
attack you and that is an interesting
thing though when we see words being
redefined or words being defined whether
it's toxicity whether it's violence
if i think that what you're saying is is
your speech is by itself
you know a violence or a precursor to
violence i'm justified in doing all
sorts of things
you know and and that creeps me out
significantly because again even if it
ends up being pointed in a good
direction initially
it's only a matter of time
you